I can't tell you how many times I've had
a stripper in my face and I couldn't get
his pants off because the problem is you
can't get them off over his shoes it's a
major pain in the ass not to mention
as a performance aspect it's not very
slick it's not sexy you're fumbling
around but fortunately I came up with a
solution
presenting
laughs
Breakaway pants
things are going well but my goals have
changed I have changed I'm going to
start my own business
[Music]
you need a choreographer and I do enjoy
a challenge
Chippendales is my creation I hired him
every cent I have I've put into this
club
You're a murderer
black hair is both stigmatized and
celebrated black hair is Art I'm telling
you ordinarrative and telling your story
so hard to tame and control but that's
how I am we all want to be free
you do not need hair to wear a crown
feel like it's just a conversation about
hair but
she never is
if I would have known that accepting
This Woman's invitation to go back to
her hotel room would have led to a
scandal involving president of the
largest Christian University in the
world and the president of the United
States I would have walked away and just
enjoyed my private life the fall Wells
are the Southern Gatsby they have a
Public Image but behind the scenes
they're freaks they were bringing him
into a world he couldn't imagine real
estate politics you don't know what
lengths people are willing to go and
they have so much to lose if they wanted
to make me disappear
they can do it I know the truth about
them and the whole world is going to
find out
we're now entering my universe I am the
lens the subject
and the authority
you always talk way so much like you
don't know what to stop when you have a
kid you're going to realize that this is
love
that's the real one
understand this there is a price to pay
for everything you do
Brave
stubborn
narcissistic Eva
I'm naked Mrs Clements I can see that
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
you don't think it's almost too seedy
this time no I don't decent people
supposed to be Charming
what point are you in what are you Moses
I wanted to know the exact dimensions of
Hell I'm an American journalist I came
here as a special correspondent and what
about you I'm here on a charitable
course your British friend interests me
how long have you known him
how do you know who he is who he says he
is do you know how many people are
playing in your game what did you do
things aren't as simple here as you want
to think
the world is a much more dangerous place
now that pain has all but disappeared
we've all felt that the body was empty
empty of meaning
and we've wanted to confirm that
not be afraid to map the chaos
so that we could fill it with meaning
a story about everything
career
marriage
money
friendships
satisfaction hi
how all those things come together
question
everything
the American Music Awards with
performances by today's hottest stars
who wins is up to you
foreign
[Music]